sarah tous pour soir joël robuchon vous
vous êtes le premier homme que je croise
avant l'émission s'est vu chez vous
d'ailleurs si jamais votre restaurant et
vous m'avez dit le samedi minutes
l'émission qui passe beaucoup trop tôt
je n'arrive pas et ça je vous souhaite
quand même le premier à la barbie et
pour ça je vous remercie parce que vous
sortez de vos cuisines vers 2 heures du
matin et on a la faiblesse d'avoir fini
mais si la chine veut écouter joël
robuchon il ya bon espoir qu'on passe
encore un peu plus tard
merci davance si je sais que c'est à
vous que je devais photo av amiard ce
livre absolument superbe une préface
d'alain genestar est en fait ce sont ces
la reprise de vos chroniques parues dans
le journal du dimanche
on sait la réussite de journal du
dimanche sous la direction d'alain
genestar qui vous avait demandé de venir
faire une chronique en même temps je
crois qu'il accueillait françoise du
goût pour sa chronique hebdomadaire sur
les livres oui commencé avec françois
girault voyez que c'était pas facile non
plus que je ne suis pas écrivain je suis
cuisinier à 15 ans j'étais sur le tas et
lorsqu'on m'a demandé d'écrire croyez
moi que c'était vraiment une inquiétude
et je ne savais pas comment j'allais
m'en sortir parce que comme je dis je ne
sais pas écrire donc écrire ce livre
c'est une idée de alain genestar en fin
de compte et vous savez que pour faire
la cuisine en fin de compte c'est vrai
qu'il faut peut-être le plus important
ce qui démarque les cuisiniers c'est
peut-être de fixer les parfums et les
saveurs
mais avant tout c'est le produit trouver
le meilleur produit possible et donc
faire cette idée d'alain genestar de
parler du produit de ces reconnaître de
revaloriser ce produit et c'est vrai
c'est ce qui détermine toute notre
cuisine parce qu'en fin de compte on on
fait nos recettes à travers le produit
qu'on trouve sur le moment et en même
temps vous avez quand même à votre corps
défendant créer un genre littéraire
parce que deux chroniques gastronomiques
comme ça il n'en existait pas vous
d'abord vous les avez appuyé sur les
saisons c'est à dire vous n'avez parlé
des produits qu'au moment où il était
disponible et vous en avez à la fois et
tous les dimanches c'est un plaisir de
retrouver à la fois l'histoire du
produit là où en trouver
et puis des recettes ou une recette
qu'il illustrait moi je crois ce qui est
intéressant c'est ai parlé un petit peu
de l'historique et puis j'ai écrit ce
que je connaissais en fin de compte
savoir les tours de main va calmement il
fallait choisir comment il fallait le
traité et puis finir par une recette
très simple je crois à la portée de
de tous vous êtes considéré je le disais
tout à l'heure comme un des tous
premiers cuisinier français on dit même
que vous êtes un des plus grands
cuisiniers du monde
vous avez eu vos trois étoiles michelin
en trois ans ce qui est je crois un
record genre guinness vous êtes couvert
de médailles de décoration gastronomie
de 100 ans et 76 vous avez obtenu le
titre de meilleur ouvrier de france et
j'ai le sentiment vous écoutant vous que
c'est peut-être la commande hier le
titre que vous préférez ou qui vous a
peut-être le plus touché ouais bah je
crois que pour tout travailleur manuel
ou gestuelles le titre de meilleur vais
être franc c'est vraiment le plus beau
petit qu'on puisse obtenir c'est ce qui
concrétise une derrière la maîtrise d'un
ouvrier et c'est vrai que ce titre est
assez fabuleux parce que l'être jugé par
ses pairs par les meilleurs je crois que
c'est la plus belle récompense que peut
avoir un ouvrier manuel vous le sentez
plus manuels qu'intellectuel parce qu'il
ya des cuisines j'ai reçu ici alain
senderens c'est plutôt un intellectuel
de la cuisine bien qu'ils mettent aussi
la main à la pâte évidemment mais vous
vous sentez plus manuels plus artisans
plus coûté un poids de cuisinier il faut
avoir les mains c'est l'outil des
cuisiniers mais il faut avoir la tête
c'est la tête qui agit sur les mains
c'est la tête et les mains qui font le
cuisinier donc il faut peut-être avoir
la tête aussi qui travaille justement
pour refaire ses recettes pour faire une
certaine recherche
retrouvez les meilleurs acteurs dans les
maisons et à comment comprenez vous
l'unanimité total qui vous entourent les
limites et total c'est vraiment bravo
c'est la vatine l'unanimité les faits
vous qui vous entourent parce qu'il ya
des grands chefs célébrer mais il ya
toujours une polémique et vous rien dire
il ya une sorte des lauzes absolue qui
doit être d'ailleurs dangereux
non mais vous les connaissez peut-être
pas justement une vie simple et peu
dangereux il y en a bien certains vous
savez c'est un petit peu difficile parce
que quand vous allez dans un restaurant
quand on revalorise peut-être trop
justement un restaurateur
quand on arrive on vient presque pour
certains chercher des faut trouver la
faille qu'est ce qui ne va pas puis vous
savez que vous avez vous sentez comme ça
du client parano tu viennes 15 notes en
disant je vais me
il y en a quelques-uns surtout lorsqu'on
a une nouvelle distinction je prends
trois étoiles au 19 ennemis au gault et
millau ou bien classé dans un guide
aussitôt on a une nouvelle clientèle la
nouvelle a peur et qui viennent pour
voir qui commence à regarder qu'est-ce
qu'il va pas le détail qui voit ceux qui
passent leurs vacances à ces drôles de
michelin avec ça
ces promotions il ya des gens qui font
comme ça le tour de france pour aller
chercher la petite bête et pouvoir
écrire au guide c'est son gameplay et
vous savez dans la profession non non je
crois que en fin de compte quand on va
au restaurant on y va pour se faire
plaisir et qu' il s'est un petit peu
regrettable de trouver cette clientèle
mais en fin de compte justement c'est
peut-être aussi de faire en sorte de
pouvoir répondre à toutes ces attentions
et justement ces clients-là de les
contenter puis en fin de contrat fin du
repas ça se passe en général assez bien
à vous dit vous vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'à 15 ans vous étiez sur le
tapis vous avez vous vous étiez
apprentis aurélie aurélie de poitiers et
vous y avez nettoyer les légumes et
préparer les bouillons laver le sol
récup 20 curé les casseroles et un jour
vous avez dit une fois que vous avez des
toiles et des marmites et des casseroles
en cuivre pour quelqu'un d'autre vous ne
traitez plus jamais les ustensiles de
cuisine de la même façon vous savez
c'est ce qui fait un petit peu la
différence
on subit quand on est sur le toit quand
on commence comme ça que je veux très
jeune
certaines contraintes et c'est vrai elle
avait la vaisselle c'est peut-être parce
qu'il ya de plus agréable mais vous
savez qu'on a on utilise beaucoup de
cuivres et pour nettoyer de cuivre il
faut du grès du sel etc et on sait que
en séchant il ya toujours une pellicule
qui restent et le cuisinier qui a fait
ça quand ils étudient ce sens matériel
donnera toujours un coup de torchon de
dans les suivra par contre un qui a été
formé à l'école l'oubliera et peut-être
c'est ce qui fait la différence on
trouve des petits détails comme ça qui
se rajoutent et c'est ce qui se retrouve
à la fin avant d'avoir été apprenti vous
avez été aussi binaire vous êtes
d'origine près de winne et vous hésitez
pas la même éducation à l'esprit ni à la
prêtrise et vous rêviez aussi d'être
architecte il y avait un peu il y avait
2 2
désir concurrents oui mais je crois que
c'est le séminaire qui a déterminé quand
même la profession parce que c'est vrai
qu'à 15 ans il y avait un petit peu un
côté affectif qui manquait vous savez
d'être au séminaire il ya également la
aussi des contraintes laisse de veto il
y avait la prière c'était des journées
assez longue
assez isolé et au moment des repas
c'était un peu la lecture c'était un
petit peu l'accord passé tellement
dégueulasse que je me suis dit non mais
c'était d'aller aider les religieuses à
faire la cuisine est vraiment celle là
c'était la détente lorsqu'il a fallu que
je trouve une profession j'ai dit je
vais faire la cuisine pour moi là c'est
la détente et la cuisine de séminaires
vous souvenez de ce qu'elle voit j'étais
la cuisine de collectivité mais faites
par des religieuses qui traitait déjà à
l'époque des produits et que en fin de
compte c'est la cuisine n'était pas
mauvaise dans les cuisines du séminaire
de temps en temps quand il fallait à
volontaire j'étais toujours là mais
c'était surtout pour éplucher des
légumes mais également pour faire la
vaisselle et en 66 vous avez décidé
d'être compagnons du tour de france est
à dire vous à vous avez pris finalement
cette tradition formidable de sillonner
le pays donc à la fois d'être attentif à
toutes les ressources du terroir et puis
d'apprendre
oui en fin de compte on choisit pas en
rend compte sur son passage et je j'ai
eu la chance de rencontrer des
compagnons du tour de france qui vont
enseigner leur savoir peut-être aussi
avec une certaine moralité et vous savez
que ce qui a fait la réputation de la
cuisine française c'est quand même cette
cuisine régionale et il fallait
découvrir je crois que le compagnon le
compagnonnage correspond justement à
cette attente circuler trouver le
produit sur place où il est meilleur il
ya une cuisine de terre il ya une
cuisine de ciel ya une cuisine de mer
vous manger une choucroute en alsace à
le problème ou si vous la mangez à paris
vous mangez une bouillabaisse à
marseille j'ai pas moi 18 en bord de mer
ou des agneaux dans les api donc il
fallait connaître ce produit bon
peut-être que maintenant il ya plus de
moyens de locomotion il ya plus de
facilité on arrive à découvrir ses
produits mais je crois que pour moi
c'était d'être très déterminant et puis
je crois que les compagnons sont des
gens qui font passer un message qui font
en plus qu'ils transmettent tout leur
savoir tous leurs secrets et pour moi je
crois que c'était vraiment très
important et je crois que si j'ai réussi
enfin devant un début
de réussite dans cette carrière je dois
beaucoup au compagnonnage le quelque
chose de très surprenant c'est que vous
avez décidé qu'à 50 ans vous arrêteriez
il ya un philosophe des sciences attelé
bachelard qui disait les hommes les
hommes de science sont utiles à la
science dans la première partie de leur
vie ils deviennent nuisible à la science
dans la deuxième partie de leur vie
c'est un peu ça que vous diriez de la
cuisine mais je m'inquiète parce que
monsieur rigaud va me disais que vous
disiez tout à l'heure dans l'oreille à
60 ans on a vu une sagesse qui était
supérieur qu'à 50 ans à 40 ans c'était
pareil donc je pense que peut-être que
je ferais mieux a 60 ans mais c'est vrai
que le métier de cuisinier c'est quelque
chose qui est très dur physiquement vous
savez on se laisse très tôt le matin on
finit tard de trois heures voyez je vais
pas votre émission
et c'est vrai que je connais des grands
cuisiniers vraiment des cuisiniers
exceptionnel d'une valeur vraiment d'une
compétence et qui maintenant il va
certainement je ne sont pas capables de
produire leurs cuisines de telle qu'il
la panse tels qu'ils sont capables alors
je pense que la sagesse et de s'arrêter
peut-être plutôt le quand vous avez
quand vous dire par exemple que les
produits vous vous obsède puisque c'est
votre marque caractéristique
ça veut dire par exemple que vous
enlevez votre il ya des produits qu'on
ne trouve pas sur votre carte parce que
vous ne trouvez pas la qualité
nécessaire d'écouter je vais vous dire
chez moi il n'y a pas de l'ofs sur la
carte parce que trouver du boeuf c'est
quelque chose de très difficile en plus
on a une clientèle quelquefois
étrangères on sait que les japonais ont
la bave decobecq et un boeuf merveilleux
aux états unis en argent qu'il ya du
boeuf exceptionnelle et que en france
c'est vrai que du boeuf ça existe faut
pas croire il ya des producteurs qui
font des efforts mais vous trouvez temps
en temps un bon morceau et vous n'êtes
pas en mesure d'assurer une qualité
toujours suivi alors donc j'ai décidé je
ne fais pas de boeuf si demain je trouve
un boucher qui est capable de me faire
un boeuf de qualité j'en aurai par
contre j'ai dû vosges et un petit
boucher d'aurillac qui suit si vos qui
va les voir qui les élèves etc et je
peux dire je pense qu à paris j'ai
sûrement un des meilleurs vaut mais je
conçois où c'est un quart et un petit
morceau devant une fois par semaine nous
ouvre même boussu dour il ya toujours du
même péché mais vous savez c'est à vous
c'est exceptionnel exceptionnel quand on
le coup voyez déjà la coupe il est lisse
il a une couleur qui est merveilleuse
une graisse blanche vous mettez ça dans
la poêle au lieu d'un
leveaux vous savez clair précis le joug
qui tous l'asag on vous avait des odeurs
des saveurs ça embaume c'est merveilleux
mais vous risquez pas de chez pas de
vous le faire piquer par des concurrents
se boucher de rials genre déjà des
remparts il se glisse qu'est parce que
je savais c'est le morceau ils m'ont
fourni qu'un alors je vois pas qu'il
pourrait fournir encore d'autres vous
n'allez pas régis vous n'avez plus la
résine en ont maintenant on va
directement au fait on passe notre temps
justement c'est peut-être ce qu'il ya de
plus dur dans notre profession c'est de
trouver le meilleur produit c'est
d'aller le chercher
on va voir les mareyeurs on se déplace
on a un poisson de petits bateaux vous
savez la différence entre ce poisson de
chalutiers qui ça vient du même endroit
de la même mère mais il y en a un qui
est pêché à la ligne donc été du jour et
qui asphyxiait il y en a un qui est pris
aux fils et qui est noyé quand vous
mettez les deux d'un côté de l'autre a
dit moi il ya une différence alors c'est
vrai faire venir chez toi moi trois bars
ou quatre bars ça coûte très cher nous
on a une qualité qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel quand vous voyez ces
produits je vous assure que nous ce qui
nous fait vibrer cuisinier avant tout je
crois que c'est le produit et c'est
peut-être ce qui fait la différence
justement parce que vous savez tout le
monde a la nostalgie un petit peu de
cette cuisine ancien du passé et c'est
qu'ils étaient une cuisine masqué ou le
produit comptait moins que maintenant et
je peux dire que maintenant il ya un
retour on retrouve des produits de
qualité merveilleuse exceptionnelle et
c'est ce que j'essaie et oui c'est ce
qui était la facilité parce qu'on en
parle avec passion et c'est parce que
j'étais capable d'éclairs peut-être dans
ce livre alors vous avez quand vous
étiez à l'hôtel nikko vous avez 90
cuisiné sous votre autorité 3000 repas
par jour c'est encore c'était au cours
de la période
monique williams et moi oui et j'ai
jamais il ya quoi il ya 45 je vais vous
surprendre vous savez pour faire 45
couverts nous sommes quarante ans tout
donc il ya 20 ans cuisine et vins en
salle mais il faut savoir que nous
faisons tous le matin le premier c'est
de le pâtissier boulanger qui arrive on
fait le pain jusqu'au chocolat jusqu'au
dernier détail qui était en effet tout
est traité
et croyez moi si j'ai vaincu signée
c'est que vraiment où le moigne employés
c'est pas pour me faire plaisir parce
qu'il ya des charges qui sont très
importantes
mais il faut quand même être en mesure
de répondre vous savez très bien que
vous avez une clientèle et c'est ce qui
se produit quelques fois dans certains
restaurants vous y allez puis c'est très
bien ça se passe bien vous êtes content
que vous y retournez la fois d'après
c'est moins bien qu est ce qui se
produit c'est que quand vous avez
40 clients par exemple qui arrivent en
même temps il faut faire face dès fois
il ya quatre places cinq plats pas
personnes ont regardé ses plats qu'ils
sont fermement multiplier il faut de la
main d'oeuvre pour les faire donc ceux
qui n'ont pas assez de personnel et
quelquefois que justement il ya une
baisse de la qualité donc si on veut
vraiment une qualité suivi et en plus
moi j'ai une chance inouïe c'est que
c'est complet tout le temps midi et soir
voilà bah écoutez les dimanches et quel
beau dimanche les dimanches à joël
robuchon c'est aux éditions du chêne je
voudrais signaler aussi de deux autres
livres elle et qui s'appelle dîner de
rêve c'est nicolas de rabaudy qui a fait
le tour qui a déclaré dans un grand
restaurant et vous y êtes évidemment
célébrer comme il se doit c'est chez
solar et puis une petite collection vous
n'êtes pas seul puisque on retrouve jean
michel lorain on trouve marc meneau de
vézelay mais vous êtes aussi c'est aux
éditions de la lanterne c'est une
collection qu'ils appellent les
épicurienne et sont des fiches cuisine
mais très très clair c'est magnifique ce
sont des cartes je crois qu'ils ne
servent à rien alors au moment des fêtes
de fin d'année pour envoyer ses voeux un
poisson devient fait très bien imprimer
puis derrière il ya la recette qui
expliquait ses taux il enveloppe pour
original et nouveau
voilà donc ça c'est aux éditions de la
landelle mais je rappelle les dimanches
de joël robuchon éditions du chêne
[Musique]